c'est bien sûr une très bonne idée donc
actuellement à poney dans une situation
tout à fait déplaisantes qui étaient les
entreprises multinationales peuvent plus
ou moins choisir le pays où une
déclarent leurs profits et donc sa paire
loeb multinationale de hédé très peu
d'impôts et du coup les multinationales
sont devenus extrêmement riche beaucoup
plus riches que les états il ya deux
éléments favorables actuellement d'un
côté l'élection john barry ted que
tournant la politique économique
américaine et de l'autre le fait que les
états aujourd'hui on d'importants
besoins de financement liés à toutes les
dépenses qui ont été faits pour le
coffee nos dépenses qui va falloir faire
pour la transition écologique et donc ne
tolère plus la fluidité représentent les
paradis fiscaux
on voit bien qu il ya des plans de
relance qui ont été lancés les plans
massifs particulièrement aux états unis
un job hayden a annoncé un premier plan
en mars 2009 100 milliards de dollars et
il en prévoit deux autres d'à peu près
de 1200 milliards pour le premier et
plus de mille milliards de dollars pour
le second donc il va bel et bien falloir
le financer
rationnellement en fait et bleu il
adhère au projet de l'oscd -qui qui
était un projet de d'harmoniser la
politique fiscale au niveau
international et c'est est à l'étude
depuis trois ans bloqué par nos tonale
trump aujourd'hui
il a deux joe biden a besoin de
nouvelles recettes fiscales
et pour ce faire en fait s'il ya une
imposition un minimum globale au niveau
international et bien ça évitera et bien
le dôme petit fils kai et l'évasion
fiscale donc ça tombe ça arrive à point
nommé en fait et 21% qui ont été
annoncées je pense que ça va ça va ce ne
sera pas le taux qui va être
collectivement accordé or le problème
c'est que les décisions en matière
fiscale au sein de l'union européenne
sont prises de manière unanime donc ça
va être quand même très compliqué au
sein de l'europe d'arriver à un accord
cela dit à partir du moment où les états
unis arrivent en ayant décidé d'avancer
sur ce terrain là il y aura certainement
plus de pressions qui vont être données
à ces pays que j'ai cité un l'irlande le
luxembourg et les pays-bas pour accepter
une forme une certaine forme
d'harmonisation fiscale
d'abord il faut dire que le chiffre de
21% n'est pas très élevé il faut se
rappeler que jadis le tournis liesse
normalement c'était plutôt de l'ordre de
50% était petit à petit s'abaisser
jusqu'à des niveaux de l'ordre de 25% et
la 21% dont c'est déjà assez déjà pas
génial il faut bien voir que les paradis
fiscaux sont des parasites échelle
mondiale et que les pattes ça c'est pas
tolérable donc il faudra que les pays
décidés à imposer ses 21% prenne des
mesures fortes contre contre les les
or contre les paradis fiscaux c
c'est une nécessité alors est ce que la
guerre reg oeil à l'intérieur de
l'europe n'est ce que l aura lieu au
niveau mondial mais de toute façon il
lui faudra des mesures fortes
il n'ya pas d'autre alternative quand on
pense aux richesses qu'accumule google
et que le fait qu'elle a maintenant des
centres de recherche qui sont qui
deviennent de plus en plus important par
rapport aux centres de recherche publics
il ya un problème qui à la fois un
problème est politique un problème
social and economic donc les 21% sait on
peut dire une étape mais un jour il
faudra que les états se décide à prendre
le contrôle de grandes entreprises qui
ont un pouvoir un pouvoir excessif à
c'est pareil pour la finance là c'est un
coup d'arrêt et on va voir si
effectivement les grands pays riches
iront à imposer paradis fiscaux et aux
entreprises nationales la fin de
l'impunité fiscale comme je pense qu'il
ya toujours à la préexistence de paradis
fiscaux dont que ça ne changera pas mais
déjà si oui au tour n'arrive harmoniser
notre fiscalité c'est déjà un grand pas
en avant les étangs me énormément temps
à réagir parce que déjà les états-unis
fidèlement soutenait vous normal en 2
enfin fermer les yeux et soutenait alors
entreprises du numérique
celle qui réussit à amasser anisé le
territoire européen sont que nous
européens on soit capable d'offrir une
une offre concurrente
aujourd'hui bien on voit les limites il
ya eu en fait ce ce manque à gagner
jusqu'à présent aujourd'hui il ya une
urgence
et c'est parce qu'il ya une urgence pour
financer les plans de relance qui va y
avoir un intérêt collectif à se tourner
vers lé ga femmes et
allez taxer davantage